twice goddamn it the show made me cry
twice
damn it say to myself be a man be a man
like step and I sure you already guess
what it is
itsuko being reunite with his uncle is
just like ah and how they did it and the
build-up to it and then the payoff and
it was perfect all it was so
good at on top of that you got the
return of uh of all these old the old
masters the name of this episode and
sort of all these these characters that
are in the White Lotus and it's these
are the guys you want to see in the
White Lotus it's great when you see them
all there it's just like yes yes and
you're not expecting it per se but when
you see him you're not surprised and
you're so happy about it so that's I was
so cool but okay you want hear how I
cried like a okay so it's the bit
where Zuko comes in he waits for his
uncle he waits where I were to wake up
and I like that like now waking him up
and kudos big time to the animation that
I mean the voice acting is wonderful in
the writing is wonderful uh I think the
animation is really what pulled me in
big-time to this because it was just
very subtle on this stuff you get uh I
wrote he wakes up and you know he's
let's add this big yawn uh and he just
glances for a second out of the corner
of his eye and then he turns back like
he's not looking at him again and it
just that little turn was so effective
and he probably knows that he's come to
ask for forgiveness or any probably even
knows what's going on
but he's still acting like you know you
need to say the words you need to say
what needs to be said and Zuko does and
they animate these wonderful I mean this
wonderful just broken base and these
tears flowing down and it's I like it
when the animation can really properly
get crying and I think it's something
where a lot of actors and Hollywood
stuff oh that they like to do the sexy
cry you know just the looking stronger
looking sad
just the tear comes down you know and
that's it and I like it when see to me
it's much more powerful way it's like
sort of the quivering and the you know
tightening of the face and so forth you
know when it's called for I mean it's
not always called for but I like it when
it's done well because then I mean that
is just a character at their most
vulnerable I mean they can't even keep
they're trying to keep composed but they
just cannot and they're just falling to
pieces trying harder and harder but
their emotions are winning and they just
become so fragile and I think that
really comes through on the animation
here on Wednesday oh really starts to
break down and he apologizes and mid
apology maybe even not mid apology maybe
like the first third of the apology or
something like that the uncle turn
Krassin that big gives him a great big
got a market is just like you know I was
never angry at you I was just so sad
that you lost your way looked it was my
way I got it ah oh man if I can get me
that's so got me oh yeah just sort
shocked that that's the first time of
Zuko and Iroh seen like maybe tear up
but yeah it just boom right there so oh
so nicely done and that nice - nice to
see the reunited again - and it's funny
uh again I I don't know if keeping the
uncle out of this was intentional
because uh because may go past but I'm
beginning to think not because it really
pays off when you see them reunited and
you keep Iroh out of it for so long and
I think that so that when that meet up
does happen there's so much build-up
even the build-up of where's my uncle
he's over there in that tent just that
waiting room to go in they even stops
and he kneels down and he he's trying to
figure out how to do it or if he can do
it you know he just feels so much shame
and a just knows it's gonna be so
painful and so hurtful to go in there
uh and just so well done I think so much
of that comes from keeping him out of
the picture
so a very effective airy very effective
but on top of that you got egg going
through the past avatars the past lives
to figure out what he's supposed to do
to defeat the Fire Lord and all of them
are pretty much saying whatever you do
whatever you do you have to do it if
that makes sense or whatever has to be
done has to be done essentially um and
he's not giving the advice he needs he's
hearing past stories but he's not
getting or at least he's not
comprehending an answer that satisfies
him uh and finally it turns out the
thing that he's on I guess is a lion
turtle I think is what's called or was a
turtle lion I can't remember but he's on
this massive thing that looks like the
turtle from neverending story and pretty
much has a pretty much has like the same
wisdom to I mean sort of gives in the
information Eadie's which um was hard
for me to follow I'm not gonna lie it's
or sounded like the our information
everybody gave but uh maybe he'll make
sense I don't know uh and it touches him
as wells and how gives them some sort of
not heck I don't know is it the sense
are Bheema like blows out of him and
apparently that's like a really really
big thing whatever it means uh so yeah
yes so you got and and finally you see
the comet coming down and what is this
gonna add up to you know what any it
looks like the comet is here and I don't
think egg is at the fire you know he's
not in front of a fire Lord yet so it
sort of looks like he's either going to
be too late or it's gonna get them just
as the comet is coming so what's the
revelation he's come to what's it's all
gonna mean there's a battle plan going
on now with the other kids they're gonna
try and put this all together so yeah
now things are they're getting good man
I mean this is like just before the big
final two and I still don't know exactly
what the resolution is gonna be and that
that's very exciting it's very excite
going into this knowing there's
obviously got to be a big battle they're
building up some sort of big battle here
but it's also gonna be this big face-off
between gang and the Fire Lord and kind
of himself too you know what you with
what choice he's gonna make so yeah I'm
gonna try thinking what else on this
episode this was this is a real good one
uh I love all the people in the White
Lotus I love the return to the uncle I
love eggs journey uh in word I was very
nicely done
and I like the big to be continued
what's gonna happen so yeah I'm like man
I'm hype to see where this is all gonna
go uh can't can't think of too much else
just you know twice man got me twice act
so there you go maybe I'll get me a
third time and the nice are maybe even
four with the next two episodes so we'll
see what happens
um that's about it getting close guys
only two more left we'll see in those
two